hey everyone my name is Jake and
tomorrow and I got the chance to play
cyberpunk 2077 last week we asked you
for some questions and then we were
gonna go through and answer them
well we've got a ton of questions here
and we're gonna go through these but
before we do that if you want more stuff
on cyberpunk make sure to check out our
videos we have up on GameSpot right now
because there are a ton and there are
more coming but anyway without further
ado should we get to this mm-hmm
first one's from Adrienne Denis Adrienne
Denis Denis Denis probably Denis are we
getting any Witcher 3 Easter eggs I
believe there is one Witcher 3 Easter I
got the star I didn't see it myself
but I heard whispers of it did you see
it yes so the only reason I added this
was because II D are Australian editor
mentioned that he did see a magazine
with Siri on it so I figured I'd add
that in if there are more Easter eggs
who knows I'm sure there are but as of
now we do have that you can find a
magazine with Siri on yeah there's
almost certainly gonna be loads I bet
you you will find a quaint card I bet
you'll get a silver sword I bet you
you'll have some sort of garel over the
customization option I think it would be
well the CD Projekt RED just ignore
theme time which is series and were like
forget about it yeah there's got to be
more than just that next one's from neo
visual can you tackle quests that are a
higher level than your current level you
totally can I tried this a couple times
and died you probably can't access every
single quest every single side quest
right from the beginning but they're
definitely a quest that you will be
under levelled for but you can still try
and you almost like we die yeah there's
the thing that kind of stops you I found
in my experience the quests themselves
aren't level gated the enemies around
them are involved in them I'll level get
it because they'll be too high having
said that there is ways to kind of brute
force it like for example one of the
quests that I did the enemies were way
higher level than me so I realized I
can't really engage them in combat but I
got a fair chunk into it just by using
stealth and avoiding combat entirely
however then there are like a certain
point I felt like you reach a a
point--we there's no kind of pushing
past it because you'll need to have some
ability like a hacking ability or some
sort of stealth ability that you're
currently not available to get because
of your level to kind of progress in an
effective way I imagine that the game is
open enough that people who really
really are dedicated to bending the
systems and finding like the loopholes
will be able to brute force a bunch of
quests but it definitely seems like it's
doable yeah and one way I got around to
it was just by using my cars to read
over people that were higher level than
me that kind of worked next question is
from Nathan rain does our character need
to sustain themselves by drinking eating
and sleeping I didn't I I was never told
nor prompted to eat food at any point uh
not as a necessity anyway the only
healing property I had was the the kind
of like gasp thing they use but there
are vending machines in the gear I I ate
some things but it was just in order to
heal I didn't find any that there was
nothing telling me I had the sleeper had
to eat or drink or whatever it might be
maybe there's some settings you can the
game comes out if you want to make it
like more realistic or whatever but
based on what I played it seemed like
you didn't worry about that yeah there's
no Morgana like futuristic mocha and I'm
going hey hey you're tired you should go
to bed or you're tired you should be or
you're hungry you should eat some food
as far as we know although I would be
alright for that case I have a funk
Morgana I mean maybe that's what uh
Keanu Reeves will be doing right yeah
hey hey hey samurai you gotta go to bed
next one's from Ali Atia how was the
driving in this game I thought it was
fine like nothing it's not like um
you're gonna be jumping and being like
you know this is a burnout now it's it
does what it needs to do and I feel like
is as serviceable and good as the horse
riding in The Witcher if you know what
I'm trying to say like you're not gonna
no one's out there being like you're the
horse riding in The Witcher is amazing
it's functional it gets you from A to B
is called the interesting part of the
vehicle stuff is I think it's fairly
random
some it's like written into some
missions but like you'll have car combat
sections which like a gang might just
run up on you and start trying to do a
drive-by in which case you go with
Jackie you can like lean out and start
some combat stuff but otherwise it's
very functional no better or worse than
a GTA style driving around the city but
your car is very cool and you've got
variety of cars I think yeah I drove
around in V's car which is the Quadra
VTech which was I mean it was pretty
responsive it felt pretty good to drive
and then I also drove around in a van
which felt less responsive as a giant
fan should but yeah I mean from my
experience it it seemed pretty good like
it'll be a good way to get from point A
to point B if you're not getting
distracted by everything like I was next
one is from Anthony z11 7 will there be
a lot of NPCs driving walking around the
city yeah I mean when I was playing I
noticed a ton like there are some areas
that are super crowded others that
aren't every time I'd hop out of my car
to do a mission I'd start a giant
traffic jam because my car would be in
the middle of the road and I wouldn't
bother to park it because it's a video
game park yeah there's there's
definitely a bunch of different
characters out there and they're not
just like walking around of they're like
just just walking up and down the road
like they would in I don't wanna say GTA
5 because it's way better in GTA 5 but
like previous GTA games for like GTA 4
and there wasn't like always they didn't
need to always be an inciting incident
for them to do something like you know
in GTA everyone walks on their own path
until what you punch one and then it's
like chaos for a few seconds and people
start running in different direction
that's kind of happening regardless of
what you're doing I'm not saying like if
you do that nothing happens you can like
instigate that kind of stuff by it's
also happening in the periphery so it
does feel quite alive and quite dynamic
yeah we also got in like an optics an
optic thing later in the demo which let
us scan anyone and it would tell you it
would give you like their name a bit of
details about them if they were wanted
or not kind of similar to watchdogs 1 &
2 did that which was kind of interesting
gave a little personality to the
characters you might see but yeah there
are a lot for sure next one's from Chris
check
Ponyo do our past life stories like
street kid corporate and nomad affect
the story and gameplay as we proceed
further in the game if they do how
please explain so we probably can't
answer this question to the fullest but
we can't say that the life path you pick
will affect the opening of the game and
then it will affect certain dialogue
choices you might have later and I'm
willing to bet it'll have something to
do with the story at some point but we
didn't play enough to really see yeah I
think I mentioned it in my preview my
immediately comes into play in the
street kids prologue mission the life
path mission where one of the kind of
death rookies or ever called the person
and the bartender owes a debt to when
you speak to him he's kind of
threatening and throwing his weight
about and because you're a street kid
you just remind him that he's not from
nice city he's come to night see he's an
out-of-towner and so you're like you
should be more polite to people who are
from night see we recognize who isn't
our own and we will take care of them so
you can assert your dominance as being a
kid from the streets and aware and three
smart and there are opportunities to do
that through dialog here and there and
it did kind of have an effect on that
dude he kind of backed off a bit so I
imagine that they're gonna play on that
more and more like Jake said it could
work its way into the store story in a
core way next question we have here is
from Mitch Guzman
my mom's question can you go on a date
with Keanu Reeves I kinda yeah I mean
he's in your head he's in your head so
he's paid he's living in your head
rent-free so you know every day is a
date with Keanu Reeves if you think
about it yeah I mean especially if he
serves that morgana roadway he's like go
to sleep samurai brush your teeth
samurai right that's what I really want
no I want him to be just like a Morgana
like figure that's constantly dude hey
hey go to bed
all right next question from feral
change feral changeling feral change
line something like that can we go on
random pointless rampages yes you can't
actually did this in mind I stabbed an
NC PD officer right at the beginning
because I wanted to see what would
happen and sure enough all hell broke
loose I wasn't super well-equipped so I
didn't want to get in any big fights but
yeah you can a lot of pipes start
hitting people if you want just bear in
that very GTA fashion or you just mess
around if you want and it does have that
GTA style of like police are coming
after you with escalating levels
depending on what you're doing so you
can't have that rampage UTA style
experience if you want it yeah they did
say they're still tweaking how that's
gonna work so I don't know if I want to
share exactly what happened in my game
just cuz it might be different but yeah
it was what what I saw was very similar
to GTA 5 sort of star level system next
question from koala yd our missions that
include nudity essential in the story or
can they be skipped I live with my mom
at home well I got bad news for you
because right when you start up the game
if you pick a female character you're
gonna see some titties right away
because there is there's frontal nudity
at least in that opening part yeah I
mean like it's I know how you feel I
remember being a kid and a teenager I
think the you're not gonna be able to
you won't see it coming when there is
new to you you won't see it coming and
if you're not careful your mom might see
a comment and then and then that games
going back to gamestop this guide you're
gonna get rid of it that it's always
just like oh you've walk into a room and
there's Magnum dong I imagine that's why
it's like like you won't be able to
predict it's not like one of those
movies where you're like oh whoa it's
getting a bit hot and heavy but get my
hand on the remote just in case a family
member walks in all right next question
from REO speedway is a swords only
playthrough possible would really like
to do a ninja hacker type run-through of
the game I think so I mean when I played
I used a pipe a lot I also use the gun a
lot but I mean it seemed like if I
wanted to I could have just used
my pipe for the entire time maybe you
couldn't do a sword right at the
beginning because you have to buy a
sword so you might be stuck with like a
knife or something simple but yeah it
seems like you could do that if you
wanted to why didn't this person go for
REO weed-whacking I don't know come on
that would have been better if right
there I wasn't listening to anything you
said jig because I was thinking about
REO we'd wagon but yeah maybe swords are
doable yeah sure why not
excellence from beefcake and the
question is where'd a strip club if
there's Club strips and no one's around
to see it does the strip club where does
strip club indeed I mean I feel like
they probably don't need strip clubs
right because they've got brain dance
they can just like hook their brain into
a machine and then they can just have
sex in a chair but not have sex just
yeah it's the demolition man approach
then we do the great but they're all
like the mission where you are using the
brain dance function for the first time
takes place in a kind of strip club
seedy kind of environment so I imagine
if you just take the right door you
might end up in a room with nested
reversals naked people
but yeah hurry a weed wagon it was right
there if you're watching this REO
Speedway you messed up the next thought
man I messed up well anyway those are
some questions that you guys asked and
we answer for cyberpunk 2077 keep him
coming if you've got more questions you
can find us on twitter at jacob deck or
tomorrow h will try to respond to your
questions there as well we probably
won't do another video like this but
like i said keep those questions coming
and stay tuned a game spot because there
is a lot of cyberpunk stuff that's
already there and we're working on more
as we speak now so see you next time oh
the to sleep Samurai we've got a sailor
bird
[Music]
you